looks like mighty raccoon is giving us
the hopeful fantasy we all desire heroes
united coronavirus thank you - bless you
say it now let's find out once this is
uploaded mighty raccoon if you haven't
seen this channel yet go as soon as you
can
fantastic animated videos a lot of wish
fulfillment
[Music]
oh it manifested into real well that's
fine
can't be worse than real-life countries
all over the world ordered nationwide
lockdown due to copa90 outbreak the
cities are filled with coronaviruses
terrorizing the streets
Lulay suicides ruthlessness rd monsters
look the same our solution the world
wants to return to their normal lives
quick district nine vibes how realistic
is it
it is goddamn realistic
it is goddamn realistic right yeah check
Oh what can check behind man check Tom
Hanks infected burger pension check the
Richer check just quit your roles stop
talking geez
John Cena [ __ ] hey is anybody seen John
Cena mm-hmm boogeyman found him that's
weird
Parker check and check Goku check okay
you guys you're missing where's
professor and the kids hey open the
flashlight Morty so here's the plan for
those of us in geography knowledge we
have seven continents in the world okay
6:00 in the her effective coping 19 we
will split into six different groups
I'll give the group's the Cure that I
developed to clear these continents just
find a high point in those voices when I
give you the marks I'll shoot the gear
to the sky with these guns you'll have
to shoot it at the same time god
why at the same time they will have to
link to each other in the atmosphere
wait that's it it looks really easy
we will see about that where's Thor
somewhere in the galaxy we don't know
oh you'll show up though right now am i
yeah hey if you couldn't bring him why
don't you bring more people to help us
okay
yeah that's it
let's go save the world
yes so what are the groups oh Jesus
before we continue the video make sure
to become a man and mighty raccoon
community and help let's get better
check out the membership oh we're
smoother guy there's no other guy it's
just you the flash and Sonic yeah
seriously why are the other groups
having
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
[Music]
Madhavi
not cool
[Music]
clean up the streets
Hey
[Music]
a translation
[Music]
yeah
most of them have coronavirus now
especially Josie
[Applause]
yeah
so awesome
there we go
[Music]
Oh God I need to finish the show
look at my suit you don't want to get
you indebted right
dude this is fantastic this is fantastic
about the on yourself yeah
[Music]
[Music]
Oh
No
[Music]
they can't get me infected so
[Music]
Hey what are you okay
John which got infected no not John wick
I haven't seen much behind me
[Music]
Oh
some uncanny effects
[Music]
take the gun
Hey
[Music]
yeah
[Music]
now dammit site
Marisa
[Music]
Oh
both
[Music]
[Music]
Oh shallots okay
[Music]
there but yeah we sure did good job
yeah
all that hard work and they he didn't
spell crucial right
that wasn't good same thing yes
legit cry hey can't believe it that was
what an unexpected morning legitimately
cathartic
very well done that was magical join the
mighty raccoon membership I have never
cried it's something that was so cool
and silly and then suddenly eyes like
even the text at the end I was like oh
man I don't even know exactly why just
maybe it's a combination of paralleling
it to something in real life yeah living
vicariously through the wish fulfillment
of the hero is started like getting all
introspective for a second - is this why
we love superheroes things like this you
know of what they can represent wishing
it was real there was just a whole lot
of emotions and then lately it's been
getting to me like on my own personal
end of just having to be here sure
that's fine you know like do I get an
occasional stir crazy feelings or a bit
of cabin fever absolutely it's not a big
deal because Vernon California in New
York is where it's like really crazy in
America right now there's been a death
count here obviously in California as
well I've had friends who have family
who they've lost and it's been rough and
then there's a lot of people that we
know some of our followers are people in
the medical field who have to work in
the hospitals and such to take care of
people so watching this video which I do
want to talk about just the video itself
I guess the last thing I was expecting
was to suddenly get very emotional
towards the end yeah this was beautiful
yeah in terms of just the video itself I
I think this is probably the best one
mighty raccoon has ever put together at
least on the one I've seen my viewing
and this felt like an actual film I mean
yeah short film but I felt like in an
actual short film it wasn't just some
cool little fantasy watching play out
like there was a whole tone and pacing
and mood development scene work in here
that I thought was really rewarding and
I thought were heroes United cuz I
didn't see the trailer that came out a
few days ago when I read here is United
I thought it was just gonna be
superheroes and then come to find out
you got one punch man in here you got
Dragon Ball in here Terminator Wolverine
well he's one of the super heroes Rick
and Morty he got a whole bunch of people
and I thought like the animation choices
the stylistic choices of how to blend it
in with the right
lighting as well made it easier to
believe all them in the same room
together when you're mixing up like the
way a ricktum or D look a little bit
like claymation and then you have
Saitama who looks you know like out of a
2d animation but then you got the other
characters as well in animation style to
which I don't know the words
you manage to find the right blend of
all these characters and then of course
the way you've portrayed Cove it 19
interesting because it had some of the
creatures from infinity war and then a
little bit of district 9 with mixed in
with some Last of Us development vibes
Resident Evil's with everyone relating
in real life to how this feels a little
bit like a zombie apocalypse taking that
aesthetic with that kind of look like a
dark matrix green grain her out was
great this is me this is my favorite one
you've ever done like this is the most
rewarding it was actually cathartic it
was amusing funny cool everything I
wanted from it to be got to live
something that was emotional and moving
at the same time for me likewise you
pretty much said it all and I think that
last image is kind of overwhelming in a
surprising way because it's the moment
we're all wondering about you know it's
a you see the city with the Sun on it
and you see the virus leaving sunny days
especially lately or kind of ironic
because you know of the beauty
juxtaposed with everything going on on
the ground and yeah I mean this was just
super cool super well put together and I
can't like it's gonna be only a matter
of time before you're out there like
animating big professional level stuff
because I was sitting here as marveling
and haha that man I was marveling at
just how well all this came together
even though there are different
animation styles that play and even
though you know it's not entirely
photorealistic just you know the choices
that you made and the way that you made
a little story out of this yeah that had
stakes to it and that coalesced somehow
yeah you brought all these disparate
characters together and made them work
you know and and yeah making the Cova
giving it a personified they really
reminded me of all those things you said
but especially like the Suicide Squad
monsters with a little like eyeball
things all over their heads yeah it
blends perfectly into a comic-book movie
format with generic villains except now
it's almost more effective than the
regular generic villains because it's
based on something that's really
distressing all of us for it to be
heroes United like just
another layer on top of why I thought
this was so emotionally moving in silly
world of pop culture entertainment
there's always who's better than this
which one did it better which is DC
versus Marvel things like that I noticed
I'm Star Wars characters though
interesting choice and a time like this
it is important where there's always
these reasons for divide in the world we
do have to come together we do have
real-life heroes out there right now but
we all can be heroes in our own way if I
work together in some fashion we just
got to cooperate and that's the way
humanity always overcomes everything
love and cooperation believe Darwin
actually said that anyway guys if you
haven't subscribed to my tea raccoon yet
please do one of the best channels out
there subscribe to the real rejects how
did you feel watching this video click
our notification about you note if I
would never got a new YouTube video up
last but not least it's on this with a
scuba Steve one of our artists over at
our patreon page fantastic artists John
actually specifically wanted to shout
you out himself so John take it away
yeah man just wanted to say hello to you
have been talking recently and I know
that times haven't been the best I know
things have been looking up maybe a
little bit but just wanted to send you
some love this video actually kind of
made me think of you partly because I
know recently you were selling some of
your graffiti trains and just like the
art you know and they were in the city a
lot I don't start kind of thinking of
you um so yeah I just hope you're doing
well stay safe out there and hang in
there you'll be slinging baked goods
again in no time
doing [ __ ]